Dungeons and Dragons,
at first regarded
as a harmless game
of make believe
now has both parents
and psychologists concerned.
Studies have linked violent
behaviour to the game,
saying it promotes
satanic worship,
ritual sacrifice,
sodomy, suicide and even…
murder.
This year, it's my year.
I can feel it.
Do you ever feel like…
you're losing your mind.
On a daily basis.
I mean, I feel like
I'm losing my mind right now
doing a drug deal
with Chrissy Cunningham,
the Queen of Hawkins High.
Welcome to hellfire.
But Vecna? Man!
There is no shame
in running.
Peaceful bliss
just moments away.
Chrissy?
Chrissy.
Hello? Hey, Chrissy.
Eddie.
We just want to talk.
I wanna know what happened.
You won't believe me.
Try us.
Her body just, like,
lifted up into the air.
And, uh…
She just hung there.
In the air.
And her bones, uh…
Her bones started to snap.
I didn't know what to do so,
uh, I…
I ran away.
He does things.
You there?
It's Eddie.
You remember me, right?
And we are now doing
everything in our power
to find him.
Anybody?
I say you're asking me
to follow you into Mordor.
So, Mordor it is.
-Steve.
Oh, this is so stupid.
This is so stupid.
Outside of D&D I am no hero.
I see danger and
I just turn heel and run.
Or at least
that's what I've learned
about myself this week.
Here we go again.
Yes! That was fun.
Light, but durable.
There will be no more
retreating.
What are you doing?
Never change,
Dustin Henderson.
Don't try to be cute or be
a hero or something, okay?
-You guys are just--
-Decoys.
Absolutely.
I mean, look at us.
We are not heroes.
Now for the fun part.
Chrissy, this is for you.
Game on in 20.
One.
Eddie.
What are you doing?
Eddie, no.
Stop.
Eddie, what are you doing?
-I'm buying more time.
-No.
Eddie, please.
Come get me,
you sons of bitches.
I didn't know
what to do, so I…
I ran away.
He could have run.
He could have saved himself.
He fought and died
to protect this town.
Come on. Come on!
This town that hated him.
Oh God.
I didn't run away this time,
right?
No. No, no, no.
You didn't run.
He isn't just innocent.
He's a hero.
I think it's my year,
Anderson.
I think
it's finally my year.
I wish everyone
had gotten to know him.
Really know him.
Because they would
have loved him.